more now on our top story the new us uk
australian alliance adam leung is an
associate professor
and deputy director at the center for
defense and international security
studies at the uh national defense
university of malaysia he's in kuala
lumpur thank you for being with us
so let me ask you first of all i mean
obviously that
china is has
made it very clear they're not happy
about this
but how how are they likely to respond
to this in terms of their actions in the
region
all right uh i think china has expressed
some worries about this new uh
trilateral
you know
the new alliance between australia uk
and the us
and no doubt
this alliance of these three powerful
countries
is of course targeted against china in
reaction to a chinese action in the
indo-pacific so at this moment china has
not stated clearly
how it would react but we will see that
china of course will come up with a lot
of
responses that are critical against this
new trilateral
alliance
especially
australia
will be equipped with nuclear power
submarines by the us in the near future
and of course china will be
critical for that so in terms of chinese
action in a sense that
i will see that this is a reaction to
what
china has been doing the last 10 years
especially in the south china sea uh
artificial island do their artificial
islands the nine dash line planes
using of
chinese coast guard wrestlers and of
course more recently the rising tensions
over taiwan
air flex
flying near taiwan and a lot of military
exercises so there are lots of worries
about
chinese intention
in south china sea especially in
particular and of course chinese is also
building a new
airport in papua new guinea right next
door to australia so i will see this uh
this uh australia uk us alliance is more
as a response
to what china has been doing in the last
10 years
i
uh at this moment i think china would
come up with a lot of uh
voices uh opposing this uh latest
alliance but in terms of
what uh you know direct action that we
will undertake uh it's still too early
uh to see how china really will respond
and why nuclear submarines why are they
figuring into this deal so much
all right uh i think australia australia
bank in 2016 has signed a deal to
procure 12 barracuda class submarines
from the french i think it's about 90 us
billion dollars and the latest news
today uh the french are not happy
because they're scrapping that view i
think one of the reasons is that as you
can see the barracuda plus on my race
are these electric submarines it has
limited range uh i think it's about
eight thousand eighteen thousand
nautical miles but more importantly
these electric submarines have limited
endurance it makes uh it can
be operational for three months
four months maximum and then you're
running out of deserve uh you know you
still need to return to base to reacquit
to resupply replenish your fuel whereas
nuclear uh power submarines has
limitless endurance you know it can run
underwater as long as the crew
you know can sustain that kind of
operational tempo and you can run
underwater for six months not sometimes
even up to eight months at nine months
because of that limitless endurance
operational temple and as you can see
the geographical
location of australia
for austrian submarines to sail say in
the south china sea in support of u.s
freedom of navy and
freedom of network operations of course
australia itself also
on the free
and open uh
global rules based order
you do need that kind of
long-range a long endurance capabilities
for submarines so nuclear submarines
would give you that kind of nuclear
power sometimes will give you that kind
of range and endurance
all right
frustrated with the word close to the
u.s i assume they will be acquiring the
virginia class attack summaries that
will give them extra capability to carry
uh torment
land attack cruise missiles
which the barracuda would be limited in
that sense
good to get your thoughts on this uh
adam long thanks thanks for being with
us
thank you so much